Quiero empezar haciéndoles una pregunta:
¿Cuántos de Uds. han tenido
que llenar un formulario en Internet
en el cual han tenido que ingresar
unas letras distorsionadas así como estas?
OK. ¿Cuántos odian hacer eso?
Excelente. Bueno, eso lo inventé yo.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Eso se llama un captcha.
Es para asegurar que la entidad
que llena el formulario es un humano
y no un programa de computadora
escrito para llenar ese formulario
millones de veces.
Esto funciona porque los humanos
pueden leer
estos caracteres distorsionados
pero las computadoras simplemente
no lo pueden hacer aún.
Por ejemplo, cuando compran boletos
en Internet para algún concierto
tienen que ingresar esas letras
para asegurarse de que los revendedores
no puedan comprar,
no puedan hacer un programa
que compre todos los boletos,
dos a la vez.
Ahora, esos son usados por todo Internet.
Y ya que son usados tantas veces,
muchas veces la secuencia exacta
de caracteres o letras escogidas al azar
es un poco desafortunada.
Por ejemplo, esto viene de Yahoo.
Las letras escogidas totalmente al azar,
en este caso fueron W, A, I, T
que en inglés es una palabra, WAIT,
que significa esperar.
Pero lo mejor es que alrededor
de 20 minutos después,
el email que recibió Yahoo de este usuario
["¡Ayúdenme! He estado esperando 20 m
y no pasa nada"] (Risas)
Eso por supuesto no es tan malo
como lo que le pasó a esta pobre persona.
[REINICIAR] (Risas)
Les puedo contar historias divertidas
de captchas por horas,
pero mejor les quiero contar otro proyecto
que hicimos después de este proyecto.
Es como la evolución de los captchas.
El proyecto se llama recaptcha.
Es un proyecto que empezamos
en la universidad.
Lo convertimos en una compañía start-up
y después Google compró esa compañía,
así que por los próximos 5 m
todo lo que les diga
es propiedad de Google.
O sea que no lo repitan.
Este proyecto empezó por lo siguiente.
Resulta ser que alrededor de 200 millones
de captchas son ingresados cada día.
Cuando me enteré de eso
yo estaba muy orgulloso de mí mismo.
Yo pensé "miren el impacto
que mi trabajo ha tenido".
Pero después me empecé a sentir mal.
No sólo son odiosos, sino además,
cada vez que alguien ingresa
un captcha realmente
pierden alrededor de
10 segundos de su tiempo.
Y si multiplicamos 10 s por 200 millones
llegamos a que
toda la humanidad está perdiendo
alrededor de 500 000 horas diarias
ingresando captchas en Internet.
Entonces me empecé a sentir mal.
Y me puse a pensar:
¿será que existe alguna manera?
o ¿cómo podemos utilizar este esfuerzo
para el bien de la humanidad?
Durante esos 10 s que alguien
está ingresando un captcha
su cerebro está haciendo algo increíble.
Su cerebro está haciendo algo
que las computadoras aún no pueden hacer.
Será que podemos
hacer que hagan algo que sea
beneficioso para la humanidad.
¿O existe algún problema gigantesco
que aún no podemos lograr
que las computadoras resuelvan
pero que podemos dividir
en pedacitos chiquitos
para que cada vez que resuelva un captcha
resuelva un pedacito de ese problema?
Y resulta ser que sí
y eso es lo que estamos haciendo ahora.
Hoy en día, cuando ingresamos un captcha,
lo que tal vez no saben
es que no sólo están demostrando
que son humanos
sino además nos están ayudando
a digitalizar libros.
Déjenme explicarles cómo funciona eso.
Hay varios proyectos para digitalizar
todos los libros que han sido escritos.
Google tiene uno.
Amazon tiene otro con el Kindle.
Es así: agarran un libro.
Esas cosas físicas,
las han visto, ¿verdad?
Esas cosas de ahí afuera.
(Risas)
Agarran un libro y lo escanean.
Escanear un libro consiste en tomarle
una foto digital a cada página.
El próximo paso en ese proceso
es que la computadora
tiene que descifrar todas las palabras
que están en esa foto.
El problema es que a los libros
que fueron escritos hace ya varios años,
la computadora no puede descifrar
muchas de esas palabras.
Porque la tinta ya se gastó,
las páginas ya se tornaron amarillas.
Entonces la palabra
se ve un poquito diferente
y la computadora no la puede descifrar.
Para libros que fueron escritos
hace más de 50 años
la computadora no pude descifrar
alrededor del 30% de las palabras.
Entonces ahora estamos
agarrando todas las palabras
que la computadora no puede descifrar
y estamos haciendo que alguien
las descifre para nosotros en Internet
mientras llenan un captcha.
La próxima vez
que llenen un captcha
(Aplausos)
esas palabras que están ingresando
son palabras que vienen directamente
de libros que han sido digitalizados
y que la computadora no pudo reconocer.
La razón por la que ahora tenemos
dos palabras en vez de una
es que necesitamos verificar
si la respuesta está correcta.
Porque una de las palabras
es tal que el sistema ya sabe la solución
y la otra es una que el sistema
acaba de agarrar de un libro,
no sabe qué es, se la va
a enseñar a algún usuario.
Le vamos a pedir al usuario
que ingrese ambas.
Y no le vamos a decir cuál es cuál.
Y si ingresan la respuesta correcta,
para la cual el sistema
ya sabe la respuesta,
suponemos que es un humano
y como tenemos un poco de confianza
que ingresaron la otra correctamente.
Y si repetimos este proceso
con 10 personas con la nueva palabra
y todos ingresan la misma cosa
con la nueva palabra
tenemos mucha seguridad
de que esa nueva palabra
está correctamente digitalizada.
Esa es la manera
en que funciona ese sistema.
Y lo bueno es que ha sido muy exitoso.
Estamos digitalizando alrededor de
100 millones de palabras diarias.
Lo cual es el equivalente
a 2 millones de libros al año
que están siendo digitalizados
una palabra a la vez
por gentes escribiendo captchas
en Internet.
Ahora, ya que estamos haciendo
tantos pares de palabras,
también pueden pasar
cosas interesantes o divertidas.
Eso es cierto porque ahora
estamos enseñando dos palabras,
en inglés, una a la par de la otra,
escogidas al azar.
Eso puede llevar
a cosas divertidas que pasan.
Por ejemplo, enseñamos esta palabra.
Que solo es "cristianos",
no tiene nada de malo.
Pero si la ponemos con otra palabra
escogida totalmente al azar
pueden pasar cosas malas.
Por ejemplo, enseñamos esto.
[malos cristianos]
(Risas)
Es un poco divertido.
Pero es aún peor
porque hay millones de sitios,
pero resulta que este captcha lo enseñamos
en un sitio llamado
La Embajada del Reino de Dios.
(Risas)
¡Ups!
Aquí hay otro muy malo.
Un político en EE. UU., JohnEdwards.com
[maldito liberal]
(Risas)
Bueno, insultamos a gente
todos los días con esto.
Pero no solo son insultos.
También muchas veces son
cosas interesantes que pueden pasar
y eso ha dado auge
a una nueva moda en Internet
en la cual han participado
millones de personas
que se llama captchart o arte de captchas.
La idea es la siguiente.
Imagínense que están navegando
en Internet y de repente
miran un captcha
que les parece interesante.
Como éste. [tostador invisible]
Lo que tienen que hacer
es tomar una captura de pantalla.
Después tienen que ingresar el captcha,
porque así nos ayudan
a digitalizar libros, por favor.
Y después, lo que tienen que hacer
es dibujar algo basado en este captcha
y ponerlo con el captcha, así como esto.
[tostador invisible]
(Risas)
Es un ejemplo de arte de captcha.
Ahora, hay miles de miles de esos.
Hay unos como éste, interesantes.
Hay otros como este
que son más tiernos. [¡Gané!]
Y hay otros como este
que son mucho más divertidos.
[Fundadores drogados] (Risas)
Este es mi nº favorito acerca
de este proyecto: 900 millones.
Ese es el nº total de personas distintas
que nos han ayudado a digitalizar
al menos una palabra
de algún libro a través de captchas.
Un poco más del 10 % de la humanidad
nos ha ayudado a digitalizar libros.
Son números como este
los que motivan mi trabajo.
Y en particular, la pregunta
que me motiva a mí es la siguiente:
Si miramos todos los proyectos más grandes
de la historia de la humanidad.
Todos esos megaproyectos
que ha hecho la humanidad
como las pirámides de Egipto,
o el Canal de Panamá,
o poner un hombre en la Luna.
Algo curioso acerca
de todos estos megaproyectos
es que fueron hechos con alrededor
del mismo nº de personas.
Todos fueron hechos
con alrededor de 100 000 personas.
Y nos podemos preguntar
por qué es que todos usaron
el mismo nº de personas.
Y la razón es porque antes de Internet,
coordinar a más
de 100 000 personas era imposible.
Pero ahora con Internet
les acabo de enseñar un proyecto
donde hemos coordinado
a 900 millones de personas.
Entonces la pregunta que me motiva a mí es
si podemos poner a un hombre
en la luna con 100 000 personas,
¿Qué podemos hacer
con 100 millones de personas?
Y con esa pregunta
hemos trabajado en varios proyectos.
No les voy a contar todos.
Pero les quiero contar acerca de uno
que estamos trabajando ahorita.
Llevamos alrededor de dos años
trabajando en este proyecto.
Y lo vamos a lanzar
en alrededor de 30 días.
Es un proyecto que se llama Duolingo.
Este proyecto empezó
con la siguiente pregunta:
¿Cómo podemos hacer
que 100 millones de personas
traduzcan Internet
a todos los mayores idiomas, gratis?
Hablemos de esta pregunta.
La primera es traducir Internet.
Como sabemos, Internet
está partido en varios idiomas.
Una gran fracción está en inglés.
Y si alguien no sabe inglés
no puede usarlo
pero hay fracciones en otros idiomas
y si alguien no sabe se lo pierde.
Yo quisiera traducir todo Internet
a todos los mayores idiomas.
Me gustaría.
Ahora, si eso es lo que quiero
hacer mucha gente me podría decir
por qué no usamos computadoras
para hacerlo.
Últimamente las computadoras
están traduciendo algunas oraciones.
Pero como todos sabemos,
las computadoras simplemente
no son muy buenas para traducir.
Y no lo van a ser por los próximos
20 o 30 años.
Déjenme enseñarles sólo
un ejemplo de qué puede pasar
cuando traducimos algo con computadoras.
Esto es un ejemplo que encontramos
en un foro en Internet acerca de...
es un foro para preguntas de programación.
Esta es una pregunta de programación
que fue traducida del japonés al inglés
y de ahí la traduje al español
pero mi traducción es buena.
La otra es la que es mala. Ya van a ver.
Sólo les voy a dejar que lean esto.
Está pidiendo perdón
por el hecho de que es una traducción.
Esto fue hecho
con el mejor programa de traducción
de japonés a inglés.
Recuerden. Se supone que es una pregunta
acerca de programación.
Aquí viene el preámbulo de la pregunta.
[A menudo, la cabra durante la instalación
de un error es vomitar] (Risas)
Después viene la primera parte
de la pregunta.
[¿Cuántas veces como el viento,
un poste, y el dragón?] (Risas)
Después viene mi parte favorita
de la pregunta.
[¿Este insulto a las piedras
de mi padre?] (Risas)
Y después viene mi parte favorita
de todo el mensaje.
[Por favor, pedir disculpas
por su estupidez. Hay muchos gracias]
O sea que, las computadoras
no son muy buenas
así que necesitamos humanos.
Entonces lo que yo quiero hacer
es que 100 millones de personas
traduzcan Internet a todos
los mayores idiomas y gratis.
No creo que le pueda pagar
yo a 100 millones de personas.
Entonces quiero que lo hagan gratis.
Si eso es lo que quiero hacer,
cuando empezamos a trabajar
en este proyecto nos dimos cuenta
de que había dos grandes obstáculos
para lograr hacer esto.
El primero es la falta
de personas bilingües.
Yo no sé si existen 100 millones
de personas que usan Internet
que son suficientemente bilingües
para ayudarnos a traducir.
Ese es un gran problema.
El segundo es la falta de motivación.
¿Cómo vamos a hacer para motivar
a personas para que traduzcan gratis?
Después de pensar en esos dos problemas
por varios meses,
nos dimos cuenta que había una manera
de resolver ambos problemas
con la misma solución.
Nos dimos cuenta que había una manera
de matar dos pájaros de un tiro.
Y la manera es transformar
la traducción de idiomas
en algo que millones de personas
quieren hacer
y que además ayuda con el problema
de falta de personas bilingües.
Y eso es el aprendizaje de otros idiomas.
Hay millones de personas
que quieren aprender otros idiomas.
Hoy en día hay 1200 millones de personas
en el mundo aprendiendo otro idioma.
No sólo es porque los están forzando
a hacerlo en el colegio.
En EE. UU., por ejemplo,
hay más de 5 millones de personas
que han pagado más de 500 dólares
por programas de computación
para aprender nuevos idiomas.
Mucha gente quiere aprender
nuevos idiomas.
Entonces hemos estado trabajando
en los últimos dos años
es un nuevo sitio de Internet
que se llama Duolingo.
La idea es que la gente
puede aprender un nuevo idioma,
100 % gratis, y al mismo tiempo,
están traduciendo Internet.
O sea, aprenden traduciendo.
Esa es la manera en que funciona.
Y la manera en que funciona
es que cuando están empezando
les vamos a dar oraciones
muy sencillas de Internet.
Y si no saben alguna palabra
les vamos a decir qué significa,
pero les vamos a decir
"traduzca esta oración".
Y resulta ser que la gente
sí lo puede hacer.
Aunque no sepan nada del idioma
si les explicamos
qué significa cada palabra
y la van a traducir.
Y después van a ver
cómo otras personas traducen
la misma oración y así
aprende cómo se traduce.
Y después que van usando el sitio
les vamos a ir dando oraciones
más y más complejas.
Y así nos van a ir ayudando a traducir.
Así es como funciona el sitio.
Ahora ya terminamos de construirlo
y lo que estamos haciendo
ahora es sólo probándolo.
Cuando empezamos a trabajar en esto
yo no pensé que fuera a funcionar,
la verdad.
Pero resulta ser que sí funciona.
Y es increíble.
En primer lugar la gente aprende idiomas.
En este caso estamos probándolo
con personas
que saben inglés y aprenden español.
Y al revés.
Y resulta ser
que aprenden el idioma muy bien.
Lo aprenden tan bien como con cualquier
otro método computarizado
de aprender idiomas.
Lo cual es muy bueno.
Pero aún más increíble las traducciones
que nos está dando la gente a la hora
que están aprendiendo son muy buenas.
Es más son tan buenas
como las traducciones
que nos dan traductores profesionales.
Ahora, hay un truco
que estamos usando para esto
y es que cada oración la traducen
varias personas, varios estudiantes,
y escogemos la mejor.
Pero resulta ser que esa mejor
es tan buena como la que nos da
un traductor profesional.
Pero además de que a cada oración
la está traduciendo muchas personas,
otra cosa que es buena es que con Duolingo
podemos traducir realmente
bastante rápido.
Déjenme darles un estimado
de qué tan rápido podemos traducir.
Si quisiéramos traducir
la Wikipedia del inglés al español
-la Wikipedia existe en español
pero es mucho más pequeña
que en inglés, es alrededor
del 20 % del tamaño en inglés-
si quisiéramos traducir la Wikipedia
del inglés al español con Duolingo,
si tuviéramos 100 000 usuarios
aprendiendo inglés con Duolingo
podríamos hacerlo en 5 semanas.
Y con un millón de usuarios
podríamos hacerlo en 80 horas.
Y ya que todos mis proyectos
hasta la fecha han logrado
tener más de un millón de personas
esperamos que podamos
traducir todo Internet gratis.
No hemos lanzado Duolingo.
(Aplausos)
No hemos lanzado Duolingo
pero lo vamos a hacer como en 30 días.
Si van a Duolingo.com los vamos a dejar
entrar al beta privado
en alrededor de 30 días.
Ayúdennos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)